seine geschichte die exemplare steht für
das was gerade passiert
während der russland propaganda sendet
und in der ukraine die realität
stattfindet eine familie flieht aus
krakau aber ihre verwandten in russland
glauben nicht dass tatsächlich russische
bomben auf die ukraine abgeworfen werden
man hat den eindruck dass sie alle
zombies sind
der ukraine krieg er spaltet ganze
familien vor allem wenn diese in
unterschiedlichen ländern leben
natalia ist mit ihrer familie vor den
russischen bomben aus hagen geflohen
ihre schwester lebt in russland und will
von putins krieg offenbar nichts wissen
stattdessen und glaubt sie der
propaganda des kreml
sie sagt nein du verstehst es nicht das
sind eure leute die euch beschießen ich
kann einfach nicht mehr mit ihr sprechen
und man hat den eindruck dass sie alle
zombies sind sie bestehen darauf dass
sie recht haben sie sagen dass sie uns
beschützen dass sie für uns humanitäre
hilfe sammeln
unfassbare aussagen natalia befindet
sich mit ihrer familie in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft in lemberg so
schnell es geht wollen sie richtung
polen was danach passiert ist unklar
meine schwester sagt dass ich zu ihr
kommen soll aber ich will nicht denn
dieses russland fahren früher habe ich
sie besucht jetzt werde ich nicht mehr
hinfahren sie sagt dass ich das nicht
verstehe und sie uns beschützen ich sage
dann aber wie beschützt er uns denn in
dem ihr unsere häuser zerstört
ukraine ein volk auf der flucht
mittlerweile haben über 15 millionen
menschen das land verlassen dass gerade
von putins truppen in schutt und asche
gelegt wird
ukrainer und russen eigentlich brüder
völker doch nun reißt gut ins krieg
nicht nur nationen auseinander sondern
auch familie
philipp head of in lemberg philipp du
hast natalia getroffen wirklich eine
unglaubliche geschichte wie hast du sie
erlebt vor allem jetzt wo sich ihre
schwester gegen sie stellt und die
einfach nicht glaubt
ich habe natalia gestern mit meinem
kollegen til biermann in einem
flüchtlingsheim in lemberg getroffen und
spürt eine ganz tiefe verzweiflung sie
verstehen uns einfach nicht sie können
es einfach nicht fassen dass der glaube
an die russische propaganda größer ist
als das was die eigene schwester sagt
und sowie natalia geht es sehr viele
menschen die dringen nicht mehr vor sie
trinken nicht mal mehr zu ihren liebsten
vor die in russland leben und sie sagen
ja wir hatten wir sehen es mit unseren
eigenen augen es fallen bomben auf
unsere städte krankenhäuser kindergärten
schulen werden zerstört und ganz viele
russische familienangehörige sagen nee
das stimmt nicht und wenn das stimmt
dann sind das eure leute die euch
beschießen das ist ein ganz tiefer frust
und ich glaube ich entstehen gerade
wunden die schlechten die wieder heilen
werden
verrückt du hast gesagt du hast in einem
flüchtlingsheim getroffen wir haben es
vorhin lesen die zahl der flüchtlinge
ist im moment schon auf über zwei
millionen gestiegen 1,2 millionen davon
allein gehen weiter nach polen und viele
kommen eben über lemberg dort wie ist
die situation in dieser westukrainischen
stadt im moment bei dir ja die lage in
lemberg wird immer angespannter vor
allem natürlich am hauptbahnhof dieser
hauptbahnhof das ist eines der letzten
tore aus der ukraine in die europäische
union geworden da kommen täglich
zehntausende menschen an und 10.000 das
versuchen dann auch sofort weiter zu
fahren aber die wartezeiten an den
bahnhöfen am bahnhof ist wirklich
unglaublich lang die menschen müssen zum
teil länger als 24 stunden warten man
versucht natürlich frauen und kinder
bevorzugt zu behandeln aber ehrlich
gesagt sind es fast nur frauen und
kinder und mehr die hausen dort
natürlich in der suboptimalen
bedingungen es gibt wenige sanitäre 1
anlagen ganz viele freiwillige helfer
besuchen zu tun was in ihrer macht steht
verteilen tee wasser windeln babynahrung
belegte brötchen aber lemberg ist nun
mal dieses flüchtlingszentrum der ganzen
keine geworden die
flüchtlingsunterkünfte sind voll man
sieht in der ganzen stadt auch spät
abends sogar noch familien ankommen
mütter die kinder die gar nicht mehr so
klein sind die 810 zwölf jahre alt sind
auf den händen tragen weil die kinder
einfach so fertig sind von dieser langen
reise und von den bombardierungen die
sie in hp sony oder tief erlebt habe
anders als eben in lemberg philipp wie
würdest du es ein scherz ist verschont
putin lemberg also den westen der
ukraine ganz bewusst damit eben die
flüchtlinge dorthin kommen können damit
er dann im rest der ukraine freie bahn
hat
ja ich glaube ist es putin wichtig mit
dieser flüchtlings karte zu spielen er
sagt ja immer dass es humanitäre
korridore geben soll um frauen und
kinder raus zu schaffen das wirkt erst
mal wie eine menschliche geste aber es
ist natürlich ein vorwand um dann die
städte in schutt und asche zu legen wenn
russische truppen lemberg angreifen
sollten was natürlich nicht
ausgeschlossen wenn es bei guti nicht
ist nichts ausgeschlossen
aber dann käme es wirklich zu einer
humanitären katastrophe
die man sich kaum vorstellen kann ich
bei lemberg bislang noch verschont
geblieben ist weil es ein halbwegs
sichere hafen ist für so viele
flüchtlinge und wenn jetzt selbst
lemberg 70 kilometer von der polnischen
grenze attackiert werden sollte dann
gibt es überhaupt keinen sicheren ort
mehr der ukraine philippiak of life in
lemberg besten dank für diese eindrücke